حرب اهليه قد تكون سببا في زوال اسرائيل
عناوين سمعتم عنها مؤخرا بسبب تظاهرات
ضخمه ومتصاعده في اسرائيل منذ اسابيع
احتجاجا على ما سمي بالاصلاحات القضائيه
فما هي هذه الاصلاحات وهل يصل الامر فعلا
لحرب اهليه كل ما تشاهدونه الان احدثته
حكومه بنيامين ثنياهو اليمينيه المتطرفه
فهذه الحكومه تسعى الى تنفيذ ما تسميها
اصلاحات في الجهاز القضائي اما المعارضه
فانتصفها بانها محاوله للانقلاب على
الديمقراطيه فيما يرى محللون ان احد ابرز
اهداف نتنياهو الذي يحاكم منذ اعوام بتهم
فساد هو تقويض الجهاز القضائي والمحكمه
العليا بغرض الغاء محاكمته ومن اجل ذلك
تدفع حكومته بتشريعات تشمل اربعه بنود وهي
اولا الحد من الم القضائيه لتشريعات
الكنيست ثانيا سيطره الحكومه على تعينات
القضاه وهذا البند الذي يتمسك به نتنياهو
جدا وهو البند الذي اخرج الناس اساسا الى
الشارع ثالثا الغاء التدخل المحكمه العليا
في الاوامر التنفيذيه رابعا تعيين
المستشارين القانونيين بالوزارات مباشره
من قبل الحكومه ووفقا لاحدث استطلاعات
الراي فان خمسه وستين بالمئه من
الاسرائيليين ضد خطه الانقلاب على نظام
القضاء التي ستمنح اي حكومه صلاحيه بلا
رادع في موازاه ذلك يرى محللون ومسؤولون
اسرائيليون سابقون ان ما يحدث قد يؤدي الى
حرب اهليه خصوصا ان رقعه الاحتجاجات وصلت
الى الجيش وهذا انذار اعتبروه خطيرا فنصف
جنود الاحتياط باتوا يرفضون الخدمه
اعتراضا على تعديل نظام القضائي شاركونا
ارائكم ما هي توقعاتكم لما سيحدث في
اسرائيل مستقبلا
[موسيقى]